so you guys may have heard a couple
weeks ago CBS announced that they are no
longer gonna sell cigarettes even though
cigarettes are legal at least as the
time that we're taping this and now
seven Senate Democrats have sent a
letter to Walmart CEO Doug McMillon
urging Walmart to stop selling
cigarettes we write urged Walmart as the
number one retailer of cigarettes in the
country to stop selling tobacco products
in all of its stores the senator said we
recognize the legality of selling and
profiting from tobacco products however
Walmart's position as the nation's
largest retailer of any kind puts your
company in a unique position to
contribute to the health and well-being
of all Americans okay so I think that's
sort of interesting because tobacco is
legal at the moment and we have this
whole thing with with we'd potentially
going legal across the country - it's
slowly happening so first off before we
get into Walmart CBS has already done
this do you guys back CBS doing this
thing because in a way it could be very
bad business for them because tobacco
products do make a lot of money and
they're super expensive from all the
bitching my friends are doing yeah they
and and it's something that if there are
a hundred dollars a pack they're gonna
[ __ ] about it but they're gonna buy it
so it's one of those it's a gold mine
and if you're not selling it that's a
pretty big deal yeah so did you do you
think CBS was right to stop doing a try
thing I mean if I can even use this
organ to describe a major company they
follow their heart god bless them if
that's what they want and it makes them
look better roll the dice see if it
works but I think I mean it's gonna take
away a ton of their business people go
to drugstores to buy cigarettes that's
why you go to drugstores to buy condoms
and cigarettes right pretty much
following your heart not something
American companies often he do often do
what do you think I'll tell you in a CVS
got rid of cigarettes and they've
already lost that smoky bohemian vibe
that you have really was but so then
they're do it for health reasons and
that's why I write so I think it's still
nice that Walmart is gonna get rid of
cigarettes but they're still gonna sell
Scotch guns and ammo and Larry the Cable
Guy CDs which reports are very bad beer
okay so they're getting rid of the tea
but what about the a and the F yeah with
the you know I mean they
they sell you know just jugs of
moonshine or whatever and and I'm down
I'm supported and and shotguns and you
can get like buckshot that already
seasoned with like barbecue or mesquite
so when it goes into the animal it's
already ready to go but you can't get a
Marlboro light yeah do you guys think
that there could be an actual economic
benefit from them because people might
I've read people saying well we would go
out of our way now to go to CVS let's
say because they're they're not
supporting tobacco so we'll go a little
further if that means we have to pass by
a courier or something else to be
perfectly honest as a nonsmoker I
couldn't even if you told me right now
and this wasn't in the news which
drugstores sell cigarettes I wouldn't be
able to tell you yeah so well it's
pretty much everybody but CVS yeah and I
wouldn't have known that yeah so because
CVS is making a big deal about it I'd
say I think everyone but that one that
everyone's talking about I don't know
Walgreens no I think nobody knows nobody
cares and I'm going to CBS even before
this because I enjoy [ __ ] customer
service and that's why I like to stand
in line and be treated rudely and not be
able to find the things I want but I
like the idea that you're talking about
your friends complaining about how
expensive cigarettes and I agree when I
smoked days to smoke generics cuz I
wanted cancer but I wanted full price
it's you know I want to deal on my
emphysema that's what I'm looking for
and I spoke the lights too right because
I was it was also a health nut yeah yes
did the money stop you from smoking it
was it all health or was it because the
taxes especially how much your
cigarettes here I'm not even sure I
think it's maybe I don't know
California's like 8 bucks a pack but in
New York I think it's like 16 or so I
was in the casino in Atlantic City the
Borgata yeah been there and so I I
remember I was starting to smoke again I
was going back making one of those bad
adult decisions and ten dollars the guy
wanted for a pack of cigarettes I was
like ten dollars
give me those so but I don't smoke on it
so I haven't smoked in years so thank
God yeah do you guys think there's a
risk in companies like Walmart CVS not
selling things that are perfectly legal
because then won't it drive the price up
of cigarettes actually if you can't get
it at Walmart which is supposed to be
cheap and you can't get it at CVS well
then just these little places are gonna
be selling it and they're just gonna be
jacking up the prices even higher or is
that the endgame because
no one will be able to avoid I think
this is one of the things that I'm gonna
predict you're gonna say something to
the effect of Oh Gina if you were any
closer I'd pat you on the head but
aren't you not allowed to do that aren't
you supposed to not do that do what like
drive prices up just because stuff is
hard to get well a company they can if
they can't release it all over the place
then it naturally is going to cause
price to go in yeah yeah so do you want
me to pay you on there now no I don't
know that was the break that I shouldn't
yeah what do you think so my enemy I
give us a little economic breakdown here
if legal substances aren't being sold by
the ball charge 50 bucks a pack just
because you can't get them at CVS that's
what I'm saying but the demand will
increase as the supply goes down Dave I
don't I took about 101 I don't know much
about economics but I do know that the
price of tobacco is very inelastic and
so what that means is that I don't know
what it means but the point is
cigarettes are gonna be cheaper and more
expensive at the same time well you've
really given me something to think about
final thought oh this will all be okay
when weed is in Walmart and CBS right
that's right it is and my health food is
a health food you know that except it
gives you moobs you and you know you're
accurate fakirs cured my cancer please
god bless I mean I never had it but I
never got it either so there you go
there it's a pre cure believe me if we'd
gave man moobs bit Jimmy would be like a
Triple D right now okay